für kinder ein riesenspaß ferien an der
ostsee
obwohl es gerade mal 16 grad warm ist
die familie doberstein aus niedersachsen
ist für eine woche hier ans mittelmeer
wollen sie dieses jahr nicht
dann lieber in der heimat bleiben auch
wenn kaum jemand ins wasser geben
die ostsee hat eine temperatur von nur
18 grad
immer noch besser als ein urlaub in
angst
sonst in den jahren sind wir auch viel
umher gereist türkei wo man heute ja
momentan wohl ich gerne hin fährt oder
auch nicht solche doch alles ein
bisschen gefährlich und auch in den
anderen ländern weiß man nicht so recht
was da so passiert
von der von der seite her schon eine
schlimme zeit
hier kann man alles vergessen und
frieren muss man auch nicht in der
überdachten badelandschaft ist es das
ganze jahr 32 grad warm
und es gibt 200 meter lange
wasserrutsche der ultimative kick für
diesen 14 jährigen
auch er ist das erste mal hier
also eigentlich fliegen der relativ
geben und sonst
mallorca ergebnis was eine sonnen länder
und ägypten dieses jahr nicht
diesmal nicht warum nicht
indem es dauert in der nähe 4000 gäste
sind zur zeit in dieser ferienanlage
ausgebucht so wie in diesem jahr die
meisten hotels an der deutschen nord und
ostsee die reiseweltmeister bleiben
lieber zu hause
und warum dieses jahr nicht in die
türkei fliegen war die woche urlaub ist
schon kurz der mittel länger nach
ist auch eine frage der sicherheit auf
jeden fall auf jeden fall sie habe ein
bisschen wind bekommen mit dem nicht nur
das ist nicht so prickelnd und dann mit
kindern
wir gehen dann einmal weiter in den
schlafraum mit doppelbett und gleich
nebenan dann das duschbad alles sehr
modern eingerichtet die sind relativ neu
renoviert und so der standard
das ist unser klassisches zweiraum
appartement kostet pro übernachtung 150
euro ohne frühstück und voranfragen
können wie sich nicht retten
gerade heute morgen wirklich die
situation auf das gäste uns anriefen und
unsere telefone heiß gelaufen sind bei
denen der türkei urlaub jetzt
kurzfristig storniert wurde und die sich
dann bei uns erkundigen wollten ob wir
noch was frei haben ist so kurzfristig
natürlich ein bisschen schlecht aber wir
versuchen dann immer noch mal das was
möglich zu machen
alles kostet extra acht minuten bungie
hüpfen für sechs euro viele gäste sind
ausländer vor allem scandinavia die toms
aus dänemark sind für eine woche hier
auch sie haben sich gegen einen urlaub
in der türkei und für die ostsee
entschieden
ich wollte da jetzt nicht hinfahren
auch wenn es vielleicht übertrieben ist
denn wenn ich es richtig verstehe gibt
es im norden der türkei probleme im
süden des landes scheint es okay zu sein
aber das will ich gar nicht was
riskieren an anderen urlaubsorten kann
man sich besser erholen
27 millionen gäste kommen jährlich nach
schleswig holstein
in diesem jahr haben die buchungen noch
einmal um zehn prozent zugelegt